here now with his he's the host of
special report bret baier all right Bret
now officials what they're saying they
don't believe the outbreak was linked to
any kind of man-made biological weapons
program according to your report and
they don't believe the contamination was
intentional do we know this for certain
or is there a possibility was
manufactured is there a possibility the
spread was intentional
you've confirmed in your reporting they
protected their country but they let the
rest of the world get this virus yeah
Sean good evening there's a really zero
confidence and the people I've talked to
and publicly that this was a man-made
virus you heard Tony Tony foul he asked
this question in a way about the lab in
the White House Task Force briefing
tonight and he said that there are a lot
of studies that show that it was
transmitted from animal to human and
that it was not genetically altered that
matches what our sources said and what
were reported at the beginning that they
didn't think based on the structure of
the genome of the virus that that it was
man-made now there are the thing that is
inconclusive is exactly about the lab
but more and more dots
both open-source and classified point
right to the lab and that's why we said
increasing confidence what there is 100
percent confidence of and we reported
this and now more and more officials are
saying it publicly is the level and
extent of the cover-up China went to and
part of those dots fit in to why there's
such a point and looking at this lab
secretary Pompeo talking about it
publicly today with Hugh Hewitt on the
radio now 98 percent we do know this
from SARS that most people may not
remember SARS also was a corona virus
and according to the scientists and
doctors I've interviewed when they broke
down the sequence in record time which
is why we're in stage one trials for a
vaccine there was a 98% similar sequence
as SARS again another corona virus which
would lend itself to the the
theory that they didn't do this
intentionally meaning create the virus
that it was there what is the exact
evidence that you know that they're
giving you what are they saying
specifically behind this report that
proves us on the man-made party yeah
well they believe that this doctor sure
Xing Lee who was working in the Wuhan
virology lab was essentially working on
antiviral and immunization efforts
that's what that's what our sources are
saying that's what matches some of the
reports that were out from the
University of South China and others
that there were efforts to study these
viruses in that very lab and basically
that the non man-made part is pointing
specifically to the genetic mapping of
this of this virus right now and that it
hopped from an animal to human and it
was not altered in its genetic sequence
that's what we just that and just to be
clear and you're reporting you're saying
that it was the Chinese view this is
dangerous enough that they weren't
allowing flights in or out of Wuhan to
any other part of China but they were
allowing it to the rest of the world
which would say they knew it was that
dangerous well then you look at other
elements they're dots on the board and
that is how much they went to scrub all
of the data the fact that you can't find
some of these doctors including
searchingly who was working on it the
fact that some of the samples were
destroyed the fact that just today Shawn
that Chinese government re announced an
increase in the death total in Wuhan by
50 50 percent what a joke if that's sex
just today
unbelievable all right prep pair great
job thank you for your reporting thanks
for sharing it with our viewers